the Callisto protocol isn't coming out
in Japan Gotham Knights is getting a lot
of fixes and Modern Warfare 2 on disc
isn't what you think
the Callisto protocol will not be
releasing in Japan due to the game
failing to receive a rating there
presumably due to its violence and Gore
the game's developer said via its
Japanese Twitter account that the
localized version for Japan will be
discontinued in that anyone who
pre-ordered will get a refund reading
between the lines here it sounds like
the developers at Striking Distance did
not want to edit their game to pass the
Japanese rating so it opted against
releasing it entirely as VGC reminds us
games in the Grand Theft Auto Gears of
War and Call of Duty franchise have all
been edited for release in Japan over
the years the kalista protocol takes
place in a prison on one of Jupiter's
moons Callisto the game promises to be
extremely violent and gory in fact
Striking Distance boss Glenn Schofield
said the development team looked at
Grizzly car crash scenes for inspiration
the kalista protocol launches December
2nd for PlayStation 5 Xbox series xns
and PC this could actually work in my
favor because if I moved to Japan then
it doesn't look like I'm too scared to
play the callista protocol it's just not
available where I live huh unless scary
news Gotham Knight's developer Warner
Brothers Montreal has released a new
update for the game that aims to improve
performance issues on PC with a PS5 and
Xbox series X and S patch coming soon
this is a small patch but a more
substantial update will follow it as the
studio looks to add a mix of needed
fixes that have popped up since launch
specifically frame rate stability on
console for the PC patch issues related
to user interface bugs graphical
settings not being properly applied and
various hard crashes have been fixed the
Star Labs Mission has suffered from some
game breaking bugs in particular some of
which also cropped up during Harley
Quinn's boss fight in the Gotham
Hospital level and finally let's talk
about some Call of Duty ever wonder what
exactly your are getting when you buy a
game disc these days well in the case of
the new Call Of Duty Modern Warfare 2
you're getting approximately
0.07 percent of the actual game Twitter
user does it play revealed that the disc
size for Modern Warfare 2 is just
72.23 megabytes though the game itself
requires at least a hundred gigabyte
install on all platforms presumably this
70 megabytes is simply the installer
itself rather than any actual game
assets however it's a stark change from
even 10 years ago when video games
actually had to fit on the disks they
were shipped out on this change solidly
set in sometime during the PS4 Xbox One
generation of games and it's been that
way ever since let me know in the
comments if you lean digital or physical
only and why I'll see you tomorrow
foreign